I've been what I love about Nicole  she's a great dancer infectious she is a  mother who plays really plays she gives  great presence  [Music]  she's imperative she knows when to push  me  and when to leave me long  [Music]  as always should talk okay I don't know  how to start what I love about Charlie  he loves being a dad it's almost  annoying how much he likes that he cries  easily in movies  I cried four times me too he's very  competitive what's this  who owns Baltic Avenue he's very clear  about what he wants  he's a great dresser never looks  embarrassing which is hard for man  he takes all of my moods steadily he  doesn't make me feel bad about them he  rarely gets defeated which I feel like I  always do  [Music]  as always should talk okay I don't know  how to start with you  [Music]  you